hello everybody my name is jasprit Singh
sandsandu I'm a final year PhD student
in computer science at Harvard
University and I will be presenting our
result on random Max csvs inheriting
algorithmic hardness from spin glasses
uh at idcs uh this year this is Joint
work with Chris Jones uh and Kunal
Marvel and Johnson C Kunal mahuva is at
you Chicago Johnson she is at USC and
Chris Jones is a postdoc at bocconi
all right so the motivation for this
result is basically to understand the
ramification of a recent line of
beautiful work that links the solution
space geometry of random instances of
various families of combinatorial
optimization problems to the success or
failure of large families of algorithms
um and in particular the motivation for
this work can be seen as trying to
understand where do typical instances of
random Max csps in certain regimes fit
in this story so whether the solution
space geometry of these random Max csps
can be analyzed whether we can
understand what the optimal value of the
number of satisfied fraction of Clauses
of typical instances of random Max csbs
are and how these insights can say
something about the ability for certain
families of algorithms to succeed or
fail on them so to give you a brief idea
let me quickly mention three results the
first was that um in the spirit of in
the spirit of such results the max cut
of spiced random hypergrass when these
hypergraphs have large degree cannot be
approximated better to than a certain
constant by local classical and local
Quantum algorithms
and in similar flavor uh the maximum
independent set of sparse random graphs
with the degrees large cannot be
approximated to better than a certain
constant Again by local classical and
local Quantum algorithms so these these
results for instance give us a flavor of
the the this program on the side of the
of of combinatorial optimization
problems but they really come from ideas
that first started in spin glass Theory
and let me mention these results uh the
two most critical results for our
purposes in this area the first is that
ground states of certain so-called mean
field spin glasses and cannot be
approximated to better than a certain
constant by a stronger family of
algorithms called Low degree polynomial
algorithms low degree polynomial
algorithms for instance are known to
subsume approximate message passing with
bounded rounds certain families with
spectral algorithms as well as many
natural markups in Monte Carlo type
algorithms and in another area of the
literature in high dimensional inference
they're also conjectured to be as
powerful as low degree relaxations of
these some of the sum squares hierarchy
all right by far the most important
result that motivated our work or is
connected to our work in addition to
this result by clss is a total first
result by Fong and selke that showed
that a precisely characterized family of
algorithms called overlap concentrated
algorithms can only output Solutions
with quality no more than a certain
specific explicit constant on almost all
instances of mean field spin glasses and
furthermore there is actually an
approximate message passing algorithm
that can come arbitrarily close to this
threshold with a bounded number of
rounds
if the solutions of these mean field
spin glasses have a very specific
solution space geometry which is called
a branching overlap Gap property or a
bob for short then this the value that
can be achieved by these so-called
overlap concentrated algorithms is
strictly less than the optimal value
but by shielding Theta Jonathan and
myself we also conjectured that
sparse random Max csps almost all sparse
random access page should have ogps
and this conjecture was motivated with a
version of the overlap Gap property
which in fact is weaker than the one
that was shown by Huang and selki to
hold for me field spin glasses and note
that the conjecture is only for Max csvs
and not csvs in particular results don't
apply to csps because the unified
connections between Max csvs and
sunglasses we show turn to breakdown for
technical reasons
all right so this conjecture over here
was based on the observation that a very
prominent and important technique in
mathematical spin glass Theory called
the guerratoninelli interpolation had
already previously been used to connect
the optimal value of certain Max csps to
associate spin glasses for instance it
was known that the maximum cut of random
deregular graphs when the degree was
large but constant could be related to
the ground state energy of the stranding
club Patrick models from glass it was
known that the max cut of
spice random hypergraphs when the degree
was large could be related to a mean
field case when glass
and one way to interpret uh one of our
results is that we generalize the GT
interpolation with ideas from the
analysis of Boolean functions to
understand the optimal value of any
spice random Max CSP by looking at the
correct Associated spring pass
now a resolution to the conjecture
mentioned above would immediately imply
that classical and
are obstructed on all all instances of
almost all Mac csps and in fact not only
are they obstructed they cannot do
better than ALC and the reason for this
is that clss showed that local classical
and local economy algorithms continue to
be overlap concentrated in the sense
defined back home in cell key
all right so now uh let me informally
State the two main results we have and
then we'll introduce the formal Notions
to understand them in detail and I'll
sketch some of the proof ideas briefly
before concluding with some open
questions
all right so the first main result is
that one can actually understand the
optimal value of any sparse random Max
CSV uh by looking at the ground state
energy density of the appropriately
connected mixed spin glass so let me
briefly introduce how to sample an
instance of a sparse random Max CSV fix
a predicate
uh this is the predicate that will act
on your Clauses each Clause will help
with k
choose your Clause to variable density
Alpha to be sufficiently large so that
you are in the unsatisfiable regime
then sample Alpha and clauses
independently and uniformly at random
from the set of all width K Clauses
furthermore in these with K Clauses
every variable must be signed randomly
so it can appear as itself or its
negation
let V sub I denote the maximum number of
fraction of Clauses that can be
satisfied for any choice of input of
certain instance I where I sample from
the procedure above
then with high probability as the number
of variables get sufficiently large the
optimal value of the CSP or the maximum
fraction of Clauses that can be
satisfied by any assignment will
converge to the fraction of Clauses that
can be satisfied by a random assignment
plus a precise second order correction
that diminishes uh as order 1 over
square root Clause to variable ratio
and this precise constant in the second
order is given by the ground state
energy of a spin glass that has that is
parameterized by so-called mixture
polynomial that we will see shortly and
this mixture polynomial is chosen to be
the noise stability polynomial of the
predicate F minus its constant term for
recently so the precise thing that this
theorem tells you is that for any sparse
random Max CSP you can compute the
optimal value or the maximum fraction of
assignments that can be satisfied by a
maximum fraction of cluster can be
satisfied by an assignment the second
order Precision by looking at the right
spin glass
so the second theorem strengthens this
result to have algorithmic implications
as we promised you it says that not only
are the optimal values the same but if
we look at good solutions to both this
Max CSP the typical instance of a Mac
CSP and the spin glass the overlaps
between good Solutions have the same
support
foreign and if this is the case one can
see them as being having the same
solution space geometry and this is what
it means to look at the solution space
geometry of of these combinatorial
optimization problems and we can
basically bring back the framework of
Huang and selki from spin glasses to Max
csps to then assert that all overlap
concentrated algorithms cannot achieve a
solution quality that is better than a
random assignment plus a precise second
order uh deviation the second order
deviation is given by Al where Al is
exactly the threshold given by Huang and
selki
furthermore this ALG is strictly less
than opt when there is a branching
overlap property so let me state two
precise corollaries of these results
that immediately lead to partial
resolutions of Prior conjectures in the
literature the first corollary is that
all sparse random Max csps where
predicates have Fourier weights only on
even levels greater than equal to four
have a branching OGB the reason for this
is that the corresponding spin glass the
way the gratiton and Le interpolation
sets it up
has a mixture polynomial that is known
to be associated with a branch angle GP
and that is known due to a Confluence of
results in Kong and selki and cgp R9
so this partially resolves the
conjecture that I stated prior where the
conjecture was that most Max csvs would
have it but well at least we show that
this family of sparse random Max csps
have some form of an OTP the second
corollary that resolves in perhaps not a
conjecture but a question in the thesis
of Huang is that local classical and
local Quantum algorithms cannot do
better than to the explicit bound stated
in theorem too
which is this
on almost all instances of random Max
csps where predicates satisfy this
constraint
so this resolves a question in huang's
thesis where Fong wonders or proposes
the question as to what generality do
these ogp based obstruction results on
Max csv's holder
so it should be clear the reason that
you can rule out local classical and
local fundamentalism immediately is that
it was demonstrated in CLS 2020
to that these algorithms are overlap
concentrated
and to demonstrate that an algorithm is
overlap concentrated it suffices to show
that is approximately elliptics in a
suitable sense so we're now in a
position to introduce the formal
definitions improve sketches but I'd
like to before a proceed I'd just like
to reiterate that results should not
extend to random csps the max part is
critical
sales informal definitions the model of
sparse random Max csps we work with is
denoted to CSP Alpha f f denotes the
predicate uh it acts on every Clause the
Clause has width K Alpha is suitably
large it gives the cluster variable uh
density an instance I of this is chosen
as follows choose Alpha and clauses
uniformly and independently at random
every Clause has K variables which are
independently randomly negated
VI denotes the maximum fraction of
satisfied Clauses for the instance I
under any assignment
later on in the proofs we will work with
the number of Clauses being not exactly
alpha n but being a random variable r
that is sampleless poisson alpha n this
does not quantitatively change the
behavior of the system but it is
convenient for analytic purposes
a spin class is parameterized by its
mixture polynomial denotes a PSI and it
is a dense random non-homogeneous
polynomial of degree K Over the
hypercube so those are a lot of words
perhaps a combinatorial interpretation
of this gigantic equation is as follows
a spin glass is just a particular kind
of dense random CSP on the hypercube
what is it specifically it is a weighted
linear combination of Max Cuts over
complete hyper graphs where the cut is
over interactions that can have random
values both negative and positive so the
way to see this is that there are K
terms
each corresponding to a degree you sum
over the complete hypergraph with Hyper
edges of size I
and you slap a random and independent
interaction as a standard gaussian on
every hyper Edge and you scale them to
have equal contribution re-way them by a
constant Alpha I and sum them all up
so the mixture polynomial is
specifically given as the sum of the
squares of the coefficients the
weighting coefficients times a power of
this s parameter which as we will see is
closely related to the overlaps
anyways the most important part here is
that due to Absolute wonderful line of
work by equaira tala Khan and panchenko
it is known exactly what the optimal
value of these hamiltonians is and
the it is given by a variational
principle which I will not write out
here but certainly there's a precise
expression for the optimal value which
is what we refer to as gsed of PSI which
is the ground state energy density of a
spin glass with coefficients
parameterized by this matchup already
all right just a couple of more
definitions before we get into the proof
sketches uh multi-overlaps refer to a
generalization of the inner product when
we are given a list of vectors so given
L vectors over the hypercube and some
index into some subset of those vectors
their I overlap is nothing but a
normalized generalization of the overlap
um you can verify for instance that if
you set L is equal to two if so that is
you have only two vectors and you look
at the you can look at this definition
over both of them it just gives you the
normalized inner product between these
now the key connection between gen for
generalizing the Guerra interpolation
comes from the observation that the way
to make get uh to parameterize the spin
glass to capture the optimal value of a
random CSP with any predicate f is to
set up the mixture polynomial of the
spin glass to be related to the noise
stability of the predicate that uh who's
ins of whose instances your CSP is
sampling
so for any Boolean function it is well
known that it has a unique multilinear
polynomial representation called the
Fourier basis and as such the Fourier
basis gives a very clean representation
for a notion of the function called the
noise stability of this function under a
noise parameter row uh you can think of
the noise stability as measuring how
robust the Boolean function is and its
outputs on average to noise in its
inputs
and it is written as tabro F and its
characterization is given by a weighted
combination of Fourier weights at every
level
of the hyperq as we will see this will
make the relationship to the PSI of the
associated swing that's quite
transparent
now for the proof ideas so the first
main idea which corresponds to theorem
one where we try to relate the optimal
value of spice random Max CSV do an
Associated Spring Class on the hybrid
queue is to set up this so-called
gueratonin Le interpolation which is
nothing but a smooth interpolation
between an instance of your CSV and an
instance of your spin glass
uh for the time being you leave the
coefficients of your mixture polynomial
unsatisfied
the interpolation is such that it runs
between 0 and 1 and it is smooth to pres
and preserves the variance which is a
matter of normalization you compute the
time derivative of the interpolated free
energy which I'll introduce in a second
and basically assert that for this
derivative to go to zero as Alpha gets
large you get a series of constraints
these constraints are on the mixture
polynomial and they can only be
satisfied if the mixture polynomial uh
has coefficients Alpha I that collect in
so to speak the Fourier weight of the
predicates at every level I
in other words you need to set the
mixture polynomial of the spring glass
you are interpolating to to be the noise
stability polynomial that we just saw
minus the constant component for
centering purposes and that allows for
this derivative to go to zero and from
there it's fairly easy to see that the
maximum value of the CSP or the optimal
value of the instance of the CSV on
average will match the ground speed
energy of the spin class so to give a
little more detail the interpolation is
as follows
represent the fraction of
Clauses that can be satisfied by an
assignment Sigma to your instance I with
CSP by hir Sigma where R is the poisson
parameter from which the number of
Clauses are chosen then for every T
between 0 and 1 set the interpolated
hamiltonian to be as follows 1 minus t
fraction of the constraints come from
the CSP
raction of the constraints come from the
spin glass and we subtract away the
average value of the CSV to Center the
interpolation
it's quite easy to see that it t is
equal to 0 you will recover the CSP at D
is equal to one you will recover the
spin class so this is indeed a smooth
interpolation where the endpoints are
the spin class in the CSP respectively
you compute the free energy density
which can be seen as a smoothened
version of the maximum value of this
hamiltonian
and when we do this it's not too hard to
show that at least equal to zero so when
the interpolation is squarely in the
land of the CSP if we take the smoothing
parameter to infinity and appropriately
normalize we get the average optimal
value of the CSP
one can then invoke concentration of
measure arguments to show that the
average optimal value of the CSP is
surely the almost surely the optimal
value of any instance of the CSP where I
is chosen by the given sampling
procedure
and then the Crux of the argument boils
down to showing that the derivative is
the free energy that I just defined
previously can be analyzed by separating
into its two contributions one that
comes from the spin glass
and one that comes from the CSV
and then with the appropriate choice of
PSI one can show that this derivative is
actually independent of time and depends
on the ratio between the smoothing
parameters Square divided by the Clause
2 variable density squared
a little more calculus then shows that
if you choose beta to be sufficiently
small with respect to Alpha and take
Alpha to be large the optimal values are
the same so how do you extend the
interpolation to actually show overlap
support equivalence it's based on two
key insights the first is that you can
define a linear map a that tells you how
to couple some independent family of
hamiltonians and effective B that tells
you how strong each of those should be
coupled you can then take the partition
function which is a which is the sum
over all configurations of the
exponential of the hamiltonian with the
smoothing parameter
to be over
M inputs to the coupled hamiltonians as
given by this map a to have
multi-overlaps as we defined previously
restricted to be in the support of those
in the corresponding spin glass and this
is the key inside and basically you
rerun the prior argument but with these
two new insights and restrictions added
and that's it some more algebra gives
you the result that we desire that the
overlap support of these coupled
habitonians of the CSP matches the
overlap support of these coupled
hamiltonians of the spin pass
and now that this happens it's not hard
to show that actually you can bring back
obstructions to the spin glasses as
shown by Huang and selki from the to the
CSV lab and I'll briefly mention this at
a very high level in just two slides
or in two points so the idea as I said
at a high level is to bring back the
branching ogp framework for spin glasses
as developed by Hong and selfie to
sparse random Max csps via this
generalized
interpolation that we just showed to do
this what you show is that there exists
a linear map a that decides how to
couple uh
these random hamiltonians and a
correlation control parameter B that
tells you how strong these coupling
should be that allows the generalized
where at ordinary interpolation
to recreate the branching OGB in the CSP
land exactly as it is known to hold in
the spring glass land as shown by Huang
in selki
and once you've done this you can
essentially rerun the same argument that
Huang and selki have to obstruct overlap
concentrated algorithms on spin glasses
on these csps but with some added
technical constraints of restricting the
solutions uh output by these algorithms
do strictly beyond the cube rather than
in the convex Hull and invoking some new
concentration results on these parser
instances we have rather than the
gaussian concentration results that Wang
and selki work on the denser instances
we have to get roughly that the same
proof goes through to get the
obstructions we have
all right so that's essentially all I
have to tell you as a summary of the
results of our paper perhaps excitingly
there are a lot of open questions but
I'm going to list two of the open
questions that are directly related to
this work and came up naturally while
this work was being conducted the first
is a conjecture uh that is imminent in
some sense almost once you read the
paper by Khan in selki or our own paper
or the prior paper of gamanek jagannath
and wine that obstructs low degree
polynomials to a certain constant
although not Al
that all low degree polynomials
that claim to perform well in a certain
technical sense and aren't just
equivalent to coin flips so the
algorithms aren't just flipping coins
and getting lucky but they are doing
something non-trivial and they can
quantify how well they claim to perform
actually our overlap concentrated and
therefore not at all good algorithms how
not good by in that they cannot cross
the algorithmic threshold of Al given by
Huang and selki
um so we can give formal quantification
to this notion of Performing well and
being far from a coin flip and this is
done in the paper of commanding wine for
instance
but showing that under these constraints
load every polynomial algorithms are
overlap concentrated and therefore
obstructed to the precise constant of
ALK is challenging for various technical
reasons it is perhaps potentially easier
to show that these low degree polynomial
algorithms
or overlap concentrate on spin glasses
before because these are denser
instances and the concentration of
measure results available are larger
it's perhaps more challenging to show
that they are overlap concentrated on
random Max csps which is the regime that
we worked in in this paper and perhaps
even more excitingly the second
conjecture is that there is a unifying
set of sum of squares relaxations for
low degree
a flow degree for random Max csps that
can match the thresholds of Hong and
selki
um there is actually recent progress in
a recent result with my collaborators
the master Dorsey and Jonathan she we
actually show that they do exist SOS
relaxations that match the threshold of
Huang and salty but for a different set
of problems
that we do not know is that we want to
say that the multi-overlap distributions
of random Max csps and spring glasses
are equivalent so far we were just able
to show that the support of these
distributions are equivalent but in
order to give unifying SOS relaxations
for random Max csps this would be a
critical equivalence we would need to
show
thank you so much for your attention